Honey Lemon Chicken …
oder eine grüne Smoothie-Bowl.
Bei Instagram geht es appetitanregend zu.
Perfekt inszenierte Food-Fotos
sind der Trend im Netz.
Eines der Top-Motive: Bowls, also Schüsseln
mit möglichst vielen bunten Zutaten darin.
Die gibt es im „Daddy Longlegs“
in München auch analog.
Gesunde Gerichte in hochwertiger
Optik gehören zum Konzept des Cafés.
Maren Weiß hat es vor
drei Jahren eröffnet.
Unsere Kunden haben einen
großen Anspruch an die Bowls,
dass die schön aussehen, dass die
vor allem Instagram-fähig sind.
Und von daher ist es sehr, sehr
wichtig für die Kunden,
dass die Bowls ansprechend aussehen.
Und manche suchen sich
extra viele Toppings aus.
Mir persönlich fällt auf, dass Essen
einfach ’n mediales Erlebnis geworden ist.
Hier stehen Smoothies und
Bowls auf der Karte:
das, was bei jungen Großstädtern
gerade gefragt ist.
Erdbeeren strahlen besonders
schön neben frischer Mango,
Babyspinat neben Wurzelgemüse.
Es geht nicht nur um den
Geschmack und die Zutaten.
Es geht auch um die Kunst
des Arrangierens von Essen.
Wir versuchen, natürlich alles, ja so ’n
bisschen symmetrisch auch hinzulegen.
Also Bananenscheiben halt im gleichen
Abstand zu legen und schön aufzufächern.
Reihen zu bilden zum Beispiel,
ist auch immer ganz gut.
Also Symmetrie spielt eine große Rolle.
Perfekt inszeniertes Essen
ist längst nicht mehr nur der
Spitzengastronomie vorbehalten:
Cafés und Restaurants treffen auf
zunehmend anspruchsvolle Kunden
und reagieren. Schuld daran ist der Trend
zum „Foodporn“, einer der Hashtags,
unter dem sich hippe Kulinarik-Fans
– kurz Foodies – auf Instagram überbieten.
Längst gibt es Stars unter
ihnen wie Pauline Bossdorf aus Berlin.
Mittlerweile hat sie knapp 250.000 Follower.
Also wenn ich koche und Essen
für ein Shooting vorbereite,
dann hab ich auch immer schon
so ’n bisschen die Fotos,
die ich später erreichen möchte, im Kopf.
Das heißt, ich überlege, aus welchem
Winkel möchte ich was fotografieren.
Und das beeinflusst dann natürlich
auch manchmal das Styling
oder das überhaupt erst:
Wie forme ich bestimmte Lebensmittel
oder wie forme ich mein Essen?
Die 22-Jährige ist hauptberuflich
Food-Bloggerin.
Geld verdient sie mit ihrem
Kochbuch und durch Sponsoring.
Kein leichter Job. Visuell
hochwertige Gerichte sind harte Arbeit.
Erst recht wenn wie heute
ein eigentlich eher blasser
Spargel-Gurkensalat mit Kichererbsen
und zum Nachtisch Haferkekse
auf dem Speiseplan stehen.
Durch die schöne Darstellung
macht es bei manchen Leuten Klick.
Und wer weiß, was … welche Sinne
da irgendwie berührt werden,
wenn wir uns Essen anschauen.
Da passiert bestimmt noch
irgendwas in unserem Körper.
Aber es macht einfach Spaß, gerade
wenn eben die Darstellung schön aussieht.
Und ich hab das Gefühl, dass
gerade in der letzten Zeit
Essen noch mal ’ne andere
Wertigkeit bekommen hat.